hello everyone and welcome to what could
be the greatest game so far from
defeated candidates tournament 2020 it's
a game from round three
ding leerin versus Fabiana Caruana
Fabiano Khurana currently with a point
and a half out of two games and England
with zero other two points so not the
greatest start for the England and now
he takes on the top seed of the
tournament Fabiana Caruana
so it's basically a battle of the the
favorites of the candidates tournament
now it's it's it's such a complicated
game I hope I will be able to present it
to you so so we cover everything and I
will really try to to do it properly
because I don't remember when we had the
last time we had such a complicated game
now before we check out the game I do
have a few nice things to show you
here's a nice photo of Fabi arriving at
the table Fabi rocking the the big green
chair and dink has the little the little
blue one as you can see and also I don't
know what Fabi is holding in assent but
I don't know if I ever said this um my
favorite video game ever is Final
Fantasy Final Fantasy 7 and it really
does look like similar to the cover of
Final Fantasy 7 you have the macro
reactor there the the the Shinra train
and everything the nice green color but
it does say fidei underneath it so not
not likely but I thought you know maybe
they they just gave him the the remake
maybe a month or two before it's
actually released so there's the setting
there's some dude in the background
wearing a mask as well as it just
enjoyed that for a second and also a
let's enjoy this very nice close-up of
England there we have it courtesy of
Lerner totus official photographer of
the FIBA candidates tournament and here
we have a tweet I made prior to this
game I said after two losses dingus
two-face Caruana in round 3 what's your
prediction and I posted it about an hour
before the match actually started over
1200 of you voted you said a 19.2% said
Bing wins a 46.2% says Bobby wins and
34.5% said that the game will end in a
draw so let's see how it went and of
course your favorite head-to-head score
before the actual game there we have it
Bingley Rand tied Fabiana Khurana - to
do with six draw so equal
classical games and if we include rapid
and exhibition games then England beat
Fabian Khurana four to three with nine
drawers so there we have it a slight
edge for ding but only in faster time
formats so as d4 is already on the board
let's just keep it there
adding opens with d4 we have d5 by Fabi
c4 and c6 Bobby goes for the Slav
defense we have Knight to f3 Knight to
f6 and now Knight to c3
we decad present c4 in out a for
preventing b5 we have Bishop to f5 by
Fabi and now comes Knight to e5 so this
is all fairly standard stuff with East 6
and now Bishop to b4 sorry first f3
preparing this efore idea and the Bishop
to b4 now we have Knight characters on
c4 ding recaptures the pawn and now
comes castles by Fabi just castles and
here Bishop to g5 is is a movie you
could play here but dingos for King to
g2 seems like he didn't mind walking his
King a bit in the previous game so he
was for king f2 it's a it's a known move
but what's interesting is that what Fabi
plays next it is not a known move so
here in the position c5 and moves like
Bishop to g6 those are known but here
Fabi goes for a 5 and here ding really
really started the burn is done up until
this point Fabi didn't waste maybe a
maybe a second or two on each move and
he says it's like he knew that ding was
gonna play this against the Slav the
king of to line and he prepared
something devastating or maybe he didn't
prepared for this game maybe it's maybe
it's hard to say he didn't play the Slav
in the in the World Chess Championship
match I believe so it's hard to say
where where he prepared this form for
but most likely for being in this game
so here you have to decide what to do
and ding spent I believe some 20 or even
30 minutes on this move because there's
a lot to calculate first just capturing
the pawn results in Queen captures
Knight character Sundy won and now
Knight F as its attacked the d7 so
really a complicated position and over
the board pretty much impossible to us
you can develop defend the pawn Knight
is coming to c5 then to b3 and it's just
a crazy crazy position I c3 Knight b3 or
attacking the rook you cannot go to d1
because of Bishop the c2 you have to go
to rook to e1 and it's well for over the
board from that position pretty
impossible to assess this so that's one
option you can go for after E 5 another
one instead of D captures and e5 is the
immediate efore but here again we have a
lot of interesting choices ECAP for
Sunday for now you attack the knight
Knight back to a two attacks the bishop
and now Bishop c5 claiming this diagonal
with he captures an f5 and now b5 so
this is most likely everything that fob
you had prepared a character say
captured see captors on b5 and now if
you move the knight and now you get this
d3 checked and it's just a crazy
position King g3 this is this is crazy
even though the engine will give a NH
the white button would burn pretty much
all of his time if you went for this and
well it would just be incredibly hard to
play this so after this 'if i move
dingos for Knight captures on e5 and he
calculates precisely a Bobby's idea
Bobby was for Bush of the c2 now trying
to get the screen captures and c2 fall
by a queen captures on d4 check which
would just win back the night so here
black would just be better
so after this trip to CT we have Queen
to d2 biding and now comes c5 again
played instantly saying that still this
Bishop is still off-limits
it's your move so here basically Dean
has to choose between III captures here
which looks kind of weird or d5 so dink
decides that d5 is the way to go as the
pawn is nicely protected and if you if
you eliminate this guy here then then
you don't really have much to worry
about for example if it's from just
captures here you could just capture
with be captures and then okay you could
win back the pawn but that's pretty much
all you're getting
so after this d5 move there is the
option of Bishop to c4 incredibly
incredibly difficult move so for example
you will not be able to capture it and
then basically black is just going
after the sacrifice sacrificed pony
because if you capture it
I just blush of character since III you
remove the defender of the night here
you cannot recapture with the Queen
because just Knight captures Forks the
king and the Queen and also if you
capture with the b-pawn steal Knight
captures picks up the Queen so after
this d5 move Bishop to e4 definitely an
option but fib decides for Bishop to b3
instead goes after the pawn this way and
now being solidifies with E 4 and Fabi
again without wasting time just rook to
e8 putting pressure on the night and
here again ding really started burning
his time he went for Queen to f4 and you
do need to unpin here you have to start
activating your pieces as here your rook
is not doing anything this rookie isn't
doing anything the bishop this bishop
cannot move due to the Queen
the knight is pencil here dings pieces
are completely tied down so Queen to f4
ding finds the absolute best move and
now
Fabi goes for c4 again played instantly
saying that I prepared everything up
until this point still at home saying
that I want to play Bishop to d6 and put
pressure on your night here so attack it
twice and Knight captures on c4 and here
everyone was like yeah but what's what's
fabi's playing not what's what's the
idea here and Fabi just continued with
Knight B to d7 and it's just the he's
down two points and he just continues
developing pieces this is this is true
alpha zero chess this is a remarkable
now I completely tanked down dings
pieces and just continuing development
and okay now but Bing does a get gets to
catch his breath now and the Bishop to
c5 could be annoying at some point so
blush of the III and now Fabi again
blitz is out just Knight to f8 not even
blitz is out he plays it instantly and
the situation on the clock here after
fabi's Knight to f8 move is 33 minutes
ding and an hour and 40 minutes Fabi so
I think is more than an hour down on the
clock and here you could try a lot of
things but the Dean says I'm not I'm not
afraid of you I'm not afraid of Knight
to g6 attacking my queen yeah because
there are some crazy lines here for
if H for trying to make room for your
queen on h2 Knight g6 you could go Queen
h2 and now you you could run into Bishop
captures and c3b captures and the rook
captures on e4 now busting open White's
position because again it's impossible
to capture the rule due to this Knight
to g4 check winning the Queen so
beautiful beautiful position after
Knight to f8 so ding says I'm not afraid
of anything just Bishop to d4 and he
definitely wouldn't mind trading here as
he's up to pawns
so first Knight to g6 now putting
pressure on dings Queen and the now
comes Queen to f5 and this is a really
awesome moment in the game because Dean
played Queen to five but the strongest
move recommended by the engine is
actually Queen to c1 and this is where I
think confused fabula bit because Fabi
was waiting for Queen to c1 but Dean
played Queen to f5 Queen to c1 is
extremely complicated most likely one of
the reasons why ding didn't play it
because you run into this sacrifice
Knight characters on e4 would check F
captors on e4 and now rook the c8
putting pressure on the night as its
attacked twice and also your queen is
aligned with the rook here so here you
would see Knights to d2 getting the
knight out of the way pressuring the
bishop here and now Bishop captures on
d5 and here it's just complete madness
who could make sense of such things for
example if ecad force on d5 you will not
have the greatest of times
quint age for Cherokee 3 Queen captures
and d4 which check and black just
prevails here so what you would have to
do after Bishop characters on d5 is just
Queen to d1 unpin the Queen and now
Queen to h4 does nothing after g3 but
still it's come incredibly complicated
Bishop c6 now you put pressure on the
bishop here Bishop e3 Knight to e5 and
blacks pieces just just keep coming
forward but if being is able to survive
all of this issue to come up on top for
example kingi one night d3 captures
captures and now after attacking the
bishop King King goes to F 2 characters
captors and let's say Queen captures on
c3 you get this position after
rook to e1 maybe now you can get your
King to safety and continue playing this
game just being up material but it's a
lot of it's a lot to survive and this is
what Fabi was hoping for Queen to c1
that thing will burn too much time and
try to worry but ding played Queen to f5
and here most likely Fabi ejected at
home but he didn't have it exactly so he
here after move 18 5 he's the one that
started spending time but still dink has
only 25 minutes on the clock and Fabi
still a minute and four sorry an hour
and 40 seconds so it's just insane that
such such a difference on the clock if
one of the players is not Alexander
agree shock but here we have Bishop
characters on c4 probably this is where
Fabi Fabi release the tension maybe
maybe maybe it wasn't needed but the
problem is it's hard to find a move that
keeps the game going for example if
Knight here you're you're you can just
move the Queen like the Queen to a 4 but
also just Bishop characters on f6
because you don't mind trading Queens if
captures then just captures also instead
of this idea there's a rook to c8 always
an interesting idea after as the knight
is attacked twice and after the knight
moves now Bishop the c5 Bishop captures
rook captures and now let's say h4 so it
is possible Queen to b6 putting the
Queen on this diagonal and now a5
pushing the Queen back Queen to b4 and
the game continues but it does look like
black definitely has compensation as
thing is so much lower on time and also
the game is incredibly complicated and
all of black's pieces seem to be i seem
to be doing a lot but okay after Queen
to a5 Fabi decided to break tension with
Bishop characters on c4 we have a bunch
of characters on c4 and now Queen c7
developing the Queen preparing to bring
the rook into the game putting pressure
on the bishop and here we have Bishop
back to e to biding you could also go
Bishop b5 but then you might run into
something like Bishop c5 threatening to
pick up the disrupt characters here and
now look the e5 pushing back the Queen
Queen h3 and now Queen characters
c5 with check King F 1 and a 6 getting
the bishop all the way back to e2 so
Dean decides that he's not he's not
interested in all of this he just wants
to go back with the doctor e 2 and now
Bishop to c5 and here being placed
Bishop captures on c5 and here was a
moment where Fabi also went into a deep
think and situation on the clock is 16
minutes ding an hour and 30 seconds
Caruana so the question here basically
is do you recapture right away or is the
rook to e5 doing something and here
Fabi had the option of going rook to e5
o be captured and c5 right away but rook
the e5 again is incredibly complicated
and again who knows what might happen
here if Queen to h3 which is your only
good move here Knight to f4 attack is
the queen not Queen to g3 and now Knight
here to h5 basically saying that you
don't have a good Square for the Queen
if if the Queen goes to h4 you might run
into ideas like a g5 which were which
means that you will have to give up the
Queen so probably when you would have to
do here is Bishop d4 and just give up
some material for example night cap
force ng 3h captors Knight captures on e
- Bishop captures on e5 Queen captures
on e5 King captures on e2 Knight Queen
captures and g3 and now either Ruby g1
or King f1 you have to guard a pawn here
before you somehow activate all your
pieces and here it's a queen and rook
against two rooks a knight and white
would be a pawn so black would be better
here and this is probably what Fabi
should have gone for but it's still it's
still a question because calculating
this position from that position whether
you whether you give up the Queen here
or you go Queen to h4 that's that's
simply not not possible to evaluate so
instead of her going into all of this
madness Fabi went for Queen captures on
c5 a.width check King to f1 and now h6
so what do you do here here
ding says I'm not I'm not afraid of
anything I'm just gonna go rook to d1
here probably safest would be g3 King g2
and you bring the rook into the game but
ding just says rook to d1 and
asks Fabi what do you got I'm not I'm
not afraid of ever anything and it's a
good question what does Fabi have he
does have his down two points that's
what he definitely has and he's up in
development but if ding can get
something like g3 King here and the rook
into the game then the world in this
pawn is just well it's just a great
point so here Fabi goes for Queen to b6
puts pressure on the rook on the pawn
and the Ruby Dee - now it's ding who
plays instantly he just says okay I'm
not not really impressed Quinta III and
now look the c2 if you go rook the d1
then Fabi might repeat Queen b6 and we
might run into something like this
so instead dingos rook to c2 which is
not a bad idea
you do have a the open C file and you
also prevent black from developing the
rogue because here if locate the c8 you
just go nice the d1 and white wins the
queen is under attack and also the rook
is attacked twice so there is no coming
out of this so now after this
quinta III here we have rook the c2
like we said and it was I believe it was
somewhere during this moment where dink
had a nice sip of water and we even have
a nice image of this dairy habit
ding takes his nice sip of water and now
it's Fabi who's on the thing just
thought you thought you might enjoy that
as well and here Fabi said ok I may I
may be down two points but you're
incredibly low on time I'm just gonna
play a six and now you you come up with
something to play and dink did take some
time not a lot two minutes he can't
afford more so he found Quinta h3 and
it's a very impressive move the plan is
he wants the instead of g3 and getting
the King through here he wants to play
queen g3 Queen f2 trade Queens or just
grab this beautiful diagonal for his
queen and take it from there so here the
problem with a move like Knight f4
although it seems nice is Queen g3 and
now you don't really have a good follow
up is Knight captures you're just gonna
play rook captures Queen D 3 and now
Queen to a-1 you're out of the woods
you're just gonna bring the Queen into
the game bring the King again bring the
rook out and that's it
so here Fabi finds an interest
counterblow b5 now what what's happening
here this is a dangerous idea because if
a captures and now nice to f4 is is a
bit different because after Queen to g3
now you played this and now you no
longer have the option of bringing the
Queen to f2 because the rook to a-1
check and white thing could just resign
for example 91 Knight captures on on d5
just creating complete madness here
Queen Capra's and e3 you don't really
have the option of capturing because
then you open up in the rooks diagonal
the rooks file here so you would play
something like captures captures with
the check King f2 as the knight is
pinned and I just pick up the rook and
now it's actually black who's better
being up a whole rook of course
so after this b5 move adding says ok not
really interested in that Queen g3 I'm
just continuing with my plan
we have b4 by favi and now Knight to d1
kicking away the Queen Queen to b3
putting pressure on the rook and now
look back to d2 and I believe it was
actually at this point that the dink had
his nice sip of water not not back then
so sorry about that
and here what Fabi did with all of this
he managed to grab a pawn back and now
if he moves the Queen he starts pushing
the a pawn now it's Fabi who might
actually have something going on with
the past a pawn but still it's Dean
who's up upon so here
Queen to f2 finally the queen is
activated you're gonna play Queen d4
centralize the Queen and here at the
situation on the clock is 10 minutes
dink one hour and the third a one-hour
Caruana and they still have to make 10
more moves before brie reaching time
control so here Fabi goes back Queen to
d7 to make room for pushing the pawn and
also if g3 with ID idea of hiding the
king you might have something with Queen
to h3 check which is what the dingos for
g3 we have Quinta h3 check and now the
problem is if you block with the Queen
the Queen just goes back and you still
don't have a good way of getting the
Queen the king out and the rook into the
game because if King f2 just a sorry I
meant not Queen d7 Queen c8 because now
if king of two you could go Queen the c5
check which the King back and just maybe
then start pushing your
so here after Keith Quint age three
check with King the G one biting and now
a five Fabi starts pushing the a pond
maybe maybe he can create a past a point
we have pointed be for now nicely
centralizing the Queen and the now comes
the knife to h5 and here first
Dean kicks away the Queen Knights the F
do we have Queen back to D seven and now
Dean again shows that he's not afraid of
any ghosts pushes f4 and here you don't
really have a good way of replying to
this move the knight is under attack the
problem is if you move the knight Knight
f6 e 5 is coming and now this is just
complete madness there's nothing much
you can do here tonight has to go to h7
and it is just an incredibly sad
position for Fabi
so after f4 Bobbie said ok there's no
more waiting here I have to go for it
and that's pretty much it
Knight captures on H on f4 and okay Dean
characters in the knight characters here
and a plus for Fabi is that the ding is
down to only 7 minutes on the clock
whereas Fabi has some 36 minutes on the
clock
we have King to f1 not allowing any and
any checks from h3 by the knight and
also to keep an eye on the bishop here
if needed so Queen to d6 asking what
what what you do want to do here keeping
an eye on the e5 square so white
kamikochi 5 and also maybe if the rook
moves maybe h2 is the target but very
unlikely
so rook the g1 biding is saying that
okay it's me who's threatening mate now
and you don't really have a good defense
here against this if Knight to g6 yes
you defend but you shouldn't be moving
the pieces away from the White King
after you just sacrifice the piece for
the attack that's not how attacking
works so here Bobby goes for f6 and now
Bishop to b5 ding is now going all out
the machine mode attacking the rook but
basically just grabbing a tempo here
because he wants to play Bishop to c6
and with this Bishop on barrier he will
completely nullify any both of fabi's
rooks as you will not be able to use the
the C file so here Fabi instead went for
rook to e7
but now just b3 now keeping an eye on on
a4 so far we cannot create
spawn will look the f8 and now comes
look the c2 preparing a nice rook lift
to grab even more space with Knights the
e6 by Fabi the Queen is undefended so
captures of course is impossible Queen
back to III and now Knight to g5 so far
be definitely making some progress but
being says that will not do we have h4
pushing the knight back Knight to the f7
and the now comes rook the c6 and now
fabi's pieces are getting pushed back
which is very very unfortunate since
fabi's the one who sacrificed the piece
for the attack but it wasn't a an idea
like let's just sacrifice a piece and
try and attack it was a last resort so
Queen to b8 now putting pressure on the
bishop and now Queen to c5 also Queen to
c5 is nice because it prevents Knight to
d6 so Queen to c5 defending the bishop
also keeping around the square here and
now Queen back to d8 asking dink what do
you want to do here maybe trying to
trying to confuse him a little bit and
Bishop to c4 is definitely a nice idea
since the king is here you might have
some ideas of pushing the pawn but ding
who goes for thee for the brute force
move rook captures on f6 he's not afraid
of anything he says you've got nothing
here and the problem with this is for
example if rook the c7 let's say you
wanna try and kick away the Queen to
reach c1 you can just bring the rook
back and now after captures D characters
and c6 you go Knight to e5 now
threatening some ideas with Knight to f3
check but the problem is here you don't
have to capture the night so there is
poison in the position but if captures
then you have this Queen to d1 trick
because the knight is pinned from the
rukon f8 and now you have a nice
perpetual here King here you're gonna
check here King h2 Queen captures here
route blocks and now you have a
perpetual Queen h4 Kings you want Queen
e1 King here and the Queen to h4 check
so there is a lot of poison to the
position problem is after this night if
I move you don't have to capture just 25
check trades Queens and the white and
just wins the game
so Fabi probably considered something
like this but he says he sees that
there's not much he can go on here so
King
the h8 instead and now rooked f5 link
wants to keep the rope here so the
knight moves he just wants to trade
pieces now rook the c7 and push up the
c6 just blocking and here is really just
a move that shows what kind of a great
fighter hobby is he finds a for now that
the bishop is pinned Fabi is able to
create a passed pawn here
dink captures and Fabi pushes be three
so now Fabi has a passed pawn and b3 and
he starts pushing it very very
resourceful guy this this Fabiana
Khurana
but rook to g3 from ding saying that
okay if you pull the pawn I always have
rook to be three so for the lack of a
better move Bobby does it but look the
b3 and now Knight to d6 Knight to d6
because there really is no other move
there is no move you can play here this
is useless the Queen not doing all that
much you cannot for example capture here
because the Queen has to guard the rook
on f8 if you move the knight and then
just trade so it's very hard to find a
move for Fabi
Knight to d6 was played but now rook
captures on f8 Queen captures in the now
while you could go for a 5 it's a really
complicated move and being a very long
time well sorry thing is no longer a
long time because we've passed move 40
and time control has been reached but
still you don't want to over complicate
it for no reason if I've does look great
you attack the knight if the knight
moves you win the Queen
however you have Queen f1 here now
guarding the queening square and it
doesn't require a lot of energy to
calculate everything out that comes
after this check Queen rook captures
Queen captures and now you move the King
that you're actually okay here so dink
not interested in over complicating it
he just picks up the passed pawn we have
Queen to f4 by Fabi and the now comes
rook to b8 for the with check King h7
and now Queen to c2 preparing to push
the pawn opening up a discovery here and
now well Fabi could block with the Queen
this is just basically this is the same
as giving up because after such a move
rook to d8 attacking the knight the
thread is just capturing the night and
after Queen recaptures checked and
picking up the Queen so you'd have to
move nice to f7 but now
look to d7 further further traits pieces
let's say h5 and now real characteristic
actress and now you can go
'if i with check g6 and d6 and it's just
a game over those pawns are are all over
the board
so while queenie 5 stops the indeed the
discovery it doesn't do much so rook to
e7 by Fabi trying to create some more
poison on the board with E 5 with Czech
biding blocking with Knight to f5 and
now again you there are some really
really crazy lines here these six is
winning for ding but it's it's just
insane rook captures here you're gonna
go d7 and now you don't really have a
good defense g6 hoping to get some moves
in with the knight here as now the
knight is no longer pinned but now Queen
c3 ruins all of all your plans now if
you move the rook it's a nice shirt mate
over there and if you go for something
like nice to III check here you just
give up the Queen Queen captures and now
the Queen comes into the game and the
checkmate is impossible to defend after
you give one check King g2 Queen
captures and c6 with check King H -
there are no more checks in the mate I
will follow but this is this is too much
to go for and too much the risk when
you've played well what could be the
game of your life
so Queen the e4 biding just think I'm
just I want to trade Queens and start
pushing my D pawn and that's it
so here Fabi of course cannot accept
this he played Queen to c1 check King to
g2 and now g6 unpinning again hoping for
some Knights that III check action and
ding just went for rook to b3 also
possible is something oh it is I found
in the live chat pretty much instantly
bishop - eh this very nice tactic that
says ok if you don't do anything I'm
just gonna capture here push h5 capture
on f5 and it's game over
and if you go nice the e3 then King f3
and again you're pretty much without a
move there are no checks there are no
tricks
there is no roof 7 it's just game over
four four four four Fabi
so after g6 ding again I didn't want to
spend too much time he just played rook
to b3 just covering all these two
squares so black is without any car
play and now the point is simply
marching forward and it was in fact in
this position unmoved 59 that Fabiano
Caruana resigned the game and
experiences his first loss in the feeder
candidates tournament 2020 and dingy
gets his first win and what a win it is
really just incredible stuff fabric
through an incredible preparation ding
ding and ding just was so resilient and
he found such amazing moves it was it
was incredible to watch it was very
stressful to watch but also just just
amazing what being pulled off here today
is basically he defeated he defeated an
engine here that's that's what being
accomplished here which is if ding was
on two wins before this game and he
played this game it would be great but
playing a game like this after two
losses is just it's just out of this
world
so by beating Fabiano ding is now on one
out of three which is not great for a
candidates tournament especially since
he's the second seed but what a victory
it is and I'm sure if he had any doubts
that he can get back into this match now
after beating Fabiano Caruana who hasn't
lost a game in classical chess I don't
know for how long he he didn't lose a
game in classically in the previous
candidates tournament in he didn't lose
a game in classical in the world
championship match against Magnus
so taking down Fabi like this with such
a strong prepared line incredible but
it's something I often say okay I don't
know if it applies the top elite players
but to definitely applies to maybe some
weaker players when you when you have a
two players one place a super prepared
line and the other one is playing the
game from the start then after those
prepared moves evaporate then this
person who played the game from the
absolute start is just more into the
game he understands the position better
he knows the dangers of the position
better and then he just overtakes what
which is what happened here but it's
interesting the line we've shown where
they would have to give up the Queen or
or maybe wouldn't but probably would
Magnus pretty much saw that instantly
and he said that he was very very
surprised that Fabi didn't go for this
but yeah I did I didn't catch the
interview after the game so it will be
very interesting to see what Fabi has to
say about it and well it just blew my
mind completely so I do hope you enjoyed
it and I do hope I I presented it to
your satisfaction as it hits one of the
hardest game I've ever had to show so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Jason bar now I do
again Alejandra de tous Lorenzo veganic
Pauli Graham assault and David wood for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thankful for watching and I will see you
soon continuing the coverage of the
feeder candidates 2020 and whatever else
happens in the chess world maybe on the
day off or some like that so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day